we've got a great show tonight Oh God  mr. O'Brien huh  guess the children noticed that guy up  there I'm sorry what are you doing up  there sir oh I'm from Best Buy total  tech support I noticed your audience  applause sign was at its lowest setting  so I took the liberty to upgrade it try  it now  that's that's great that's I was amazing  thank you wait ah our applause sign is  from Best Buy nope  but Best Buy total tech support is able  to help with all your tech not just  devices from Best Buy that's right any  device I didn't even know it could do  that Hey  well thanks for all your help appreciate  it anytime Conan and remember Best Buy  total tech support can support any tech  need Wow there's a light switch on my  neck it appears so wait was this entire  thing a thinly-veiled ad for Best Buy  okay be quiet now hey hit that applause  sign again  that's why  you